I'm missing dog overdue doctor who
review time and we are now up to school
reunion in my mind the first great
episode of series two we have so much
going on here that I absolutely love and
going back and revisiting it the stuff
that I love is still so so so so so good
and there's a couple things that didn't
used to bother me but do now and that's
not to say that I'm now recognizing
flaws that I you know didn't notice
before but as my own perspective on
Doctor Who and life in general has
shifted there's some things that this
episode does that I now kinda don't like
and we'll get to those but sort of
starting with the stuff that I love
first of all there's a this is a very
Buffy the Vampire Slayer feeling episode
of Doctor Who
part of that is aesthetic cuz it's set
in a school and oh look there's anthony
Stewart heads MIDI editor he's only got
one yeah in the school it's like it's
Giles it's you know so but even beyond
just that it does have that feel and
that vibe of something weird at the
school this these people are behind a
deal and some of the dialogue as well
like there's more line especially from
for mr. Finch from anthony Stewart heads
character you know or goes ignore the
shooty dog thing I mean shooty dog think
that sounds like it's almost a straight
Whedon lift so it's got that vibe to it
which is probably why especially on
initial viewing when I was you know cuz
I had my initial hook in because I
caught the Satan pit on TV when I was in
London and then I you know went back
series 1 and I was really enjoying it
but for a while certainly upon first
viewing this was my favorite episode I
think it's because I felt
that connection and that similarity to
another thing that I already loved which
is of course Buffy the Vampire Slayer
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
neat little humorous moments like when
the when the oil gets on the cafeteria
worker and like they take her off into
this other room and you know they're
making sure Rose doesn't call an
ambulance and one of them goes she's
fine when there's smoke coming up behind
her she's fine she does that just duck's
back hit him that's I'm sorry that's
great and a lot of the things that are
done in terms of the dynamic between the
doctor and rose and Sarah Jane and which
brings us of course to Sarah Jane Smith
how awesome is it that she was
reintegrated into the show at this point
this was my introduction to her as a
character because I hadn't started
exploring classic who at this point why
you'll when I saw this the first time I
mean I knew who she was I kind of looked
up enough about Doctor Who as a thing to
know that she was a person who existed
and sort of knew what k9 was but I
hadn't seen anything with them in it so
seeing that dynamic see and she plays
off tenon really well his excitement at
meeting her like that that is a that's
another kind of a bit of a fourth-wall
break moment because you feel like well
that's that's David Tennant's excitement
at meeting her I mean the doctors too
but that's David Tennant just channeling
his own excitement of getting to do this
with her and I think it was an
interesting call and I think especially
in terms of the scope of how the
relationship between the doctor and Rose
builds to have the dynamic between the
three of them play a bit like a guy his
girlfriend and his ex which you know
Mickey points out blatantly but I think
that's that's an interesting way to play
it and mate for you know a dynamic that
was just antagonistic enough but didn't
tip over because you know sort of the
the ladies woke up to and they're like
what are we doing which was good it
needed that moment i reaiiy want to come
back to anthony Stewart head though
because I I will never ever
ver stop being irritated the fact that
mr. Finch never came back and don't tell
me uh he blew up like how did Davros
live at the end of journey's end and
besides the fact he wasn't affected by
the oil when that blew up all the other
krillitanes around him are screaming
like ah that's not affecting him so he's
obviously tougher than them he could
have survived that explosion why has he
never come back he is such a good
villain the presence that he has like up
to that point he was in many ways I feel
like the firt certainly the first human
portrayed villain that felt like he
could stand up and just face to face
with the doctor there have been some
good villains up to this point the
Daleks obviously but you know they've
got a lot of past history baggage they
get to sort of stand on a bit plus you
know Pepperpot
but then you know the empty child which
is functionally a villain is great but
it's it's a threat it's it's not
necessarily a character as a character
as someone who can stand face to face
with a doctor and say you know what he
said you know stand up to him face him
down go you're not gonna win you
believed him because he had that sense
of authority and the delivery and I
don't think it really happened prior to
that in this series and I'm not sure how
many times it's happened since and the
fact that he's never come back is just
so frustrating why does it go
hello
and the other thing that I love that he
brings is that he feels like a fully
formed character when he's talking with
Sarah Jane he actually has this
wonderful sense of pride in the fact
that the school's doing so well so like
even though you know he's got this
master plan and all this stuff he's also
like oh she's writing a piece above me
and you're like you've got an ego and
that comes across really well and that's
not especially relevant to the plot that
he has an ego like that but it's said
it's a touch that gives him a
roundedness makes him feel like a more
complete character and you know actually
sort of coming back to the school the
fact that we open up with a student who
has knowledge way beyond what he should
have for this time plays at earth that's
kind of a nice subtle ish callback to an
unearthly child the very first episode
of Doctor Who because that was Susan
that was the doctors granddaughter
you know had all this knowledge she
should not have had mmm and God heard
her teachers curious I mean that kind of
happens here only this time the teacher
is also the doctor k9 coming back is fun
k9 is a character that when used
correctly I he sparingly is a lot of fun
to have he can get overused because I
mean it's a robot that barely moves and
you know but John Leeson brings out
surprising amount of personality across
even in the robotic sounding voice that
he does for for the character Mickey's
fun in this you know I I like his use in
it but like I said there are the handful
of things that on a rewatch didn't used
to bother me but now kind of do and ones
just like a personal things one
something that the more thing about the
Marling and then one is just a nitpick
and I don't know what I'll do I'll start
with the nitpick this is what I'm most
likely to forget and that's the whole
thing this is the episode that
introduced the whole deadlock seal you
know that the the sonic screwdriver can
can't open a deadlock seal and I what I
don't like about that is just it's I
have my weird relationship with the
sonic screwdriver in the first place
because there are plenty of fans who are
annoyed to add it and feel like it's
overused
you know something that fixes everything
I don't really have that problem with it
but it does kind of bug me that we just
arbitrarily came up with oh except for
this so that they can just drop the term
deadlock every now and then when they
want it to not work whereas I mean I I
feel like it would have felt like a
proper nerfing of the sonic screwdriver
if it have been more something like you
know I don't know what this thing is so
the sonic can affect it but I don't know
what to do with it the software doesn't
know how to deal with it you know
something along those lines something
that has a little more thought into it
rather than this can open anything I'll
accept that one thing and it's not it's
not quite like that doesn't work on wood
which functions as a joke this you know
the deadlock thing just gets dropped in
and then every time I hear the term
deadlock it just kind of annoys me
because it's such a it's such a cheap
restriction on the sonic screwdriver and
I again it's weird for me to complain
about that because other people will say
the sonic screwdriver in itself is a
cheap way to move the story forward and
I'm annoyed at the way they that they
didn't put more thought into how they
nerfed it whereas other people are more
annoyed that they don't put more thought
into have the doctor does stuff rather
than just have the sonic screwdriver get
way ground I don't know different
hang-ups so the the thing that like on a
personal level I just don't love I don't
love that as a cold open a child dies
like especially given the overall jovial
sort of light-hearted feel of the
episode on the whole you know I'm just
I've never loved you know underage
character deaths and now being a parent
I find them really unsettling especially
when they're done this casually and this
you know no significance given to it I'm
not saying you can never kill a child in
a narrative but like you have a child
dies I feel like that should be
important and to have
a child just be the oh here's the random
no-name person that we're gonna kill
during the cold open to establish that
there's a threat I'm like I am honestly
really not comfortable with that
and again that's me that's my hang-ups
that's my baggage that's the things that
just don't sit well with me so that's
not an inherent flaw and the last thing
is that now the more that I thought
about it the more like grown up and now
having read watch the episode I'm like
yeah so in terms of how Sarah Jane Smith
is handled first of all Elisabeth Sladen
plays her brilliantly she's awesome in
the park and like I said the dynamic of
Slade sort of functionally within you
know the interactions of those three
characters is like the ex-girlfriend
works that's fine too but what gets to
me is how much emphasis they put on
important the doctor was to her and and
and not to say that the doctor wouldn't
have been important to her into her life
but the some of the specifics that they
plant the idea that she didn't just wait
for him she never stopped waiting for
him and some of the line she has at the
tail end like to the point of him
playing like she feels like she hasn't
been living her life properly because
she's been waiting for him to come back
the idea you know that she never had kid
is sort of tied to that no one else
could measure up to him I don't I don't
I mean I recognize that the doctors
gonna be one of the most important
periods of her life and I also know that
you know the way in which the fourth
doctor left her was not expected she
didn't choose to leave at the time that
she did so there's a recent burner to be
annoyed and have baggage about that but
the degree they take they just take it
too far as far as the extent of how just
how little she'd lived after that and
again a part of it's implied but some of
it's made really explicit that she kind
of felt like she had an empty life after
that and that feels wrong
it feels wrong for her as a character
and it feels cheapening to an ordinary
life you know the I I would like to
think that her time with the doctor
would be like if you or I had a
whirlwind jaunt you know around
I don't know around the world and you
know we come back and we live our life
after that we think back on I go yeah
that was good
I miss times like pep but it doesn't
kneecap your ability to live your life
or it shouldn't and with her they kind
of had to do that and I don't love that
idea the idea that the companions never
get over the doctor
I accept that the companions never
forget the doctor and that they're happy
to see him again but the idea that they
never get over him I don't love that as
a concept and it kind of comes back
again in some ways later on down the
series and it's it's become one of those
things that I just I again they were in
the right ballpark but they just they
they pushed it too far and it was
annoying for me to realize how much that
does kind of bother me but it also
doesn't completely sync the stuff that
works because the villain is great the a
lot of the jokes are great the character
dynamics are great the you know the
overall pace and flow of the episode is
great it's just it's a good fun episode
I still do really love and I still do
consider it to be certainly one of the
best of the second series if not one of
the best Tennant episodes but yeah
coming back to it now there are these
things that I notice and you know when
you revisit it's funny when I revisit
episodes that I didn't like as much
alright I don't remember like these much
I'm sort of hunting for what's good
about it so that I can highlight that
and try and remember it next time so
that I don't think it was just a
complete piece of garbage but when I go
back and re-watch episodes that I like I
the opposite kind of happens I can't
help but sort of look for the flaws and
goes how rose-tinted were than
Chicago's I was looking at this throw
and there you go so school reunion what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
you can do because there's buttons and
there's links whole bunch of Link's
saying you know including one to my
patreon if you feel generous but all
that sounded description check it out if
you want if you don't want to that's
okay because at the end of the day folks
you are the council and I just run the
meetings until next time this council is
a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]